Okay, so let's look at our issue quiz solution.
We have these two instructions to issue. This is the older one to issue. So
we're going to get a divide, or multiply reservation station.
Mark that this is a divide. F1 and F2. Or maybe this parameters.
Look here, you find it RS4 and RS1 are going to produce that value, so
we don't get any values from the registered file. And then we're going to update
for F4 that the result is going to come out of RS5. And now we're done with
this instruction. This instruction cannot issue. Because it's a multiplication
instruction, all of the divide multiplier reservation stations ar busy.
So until one of these finishes, this instruction isn't going to issue, and
so now our issue part is going to be stalled until that is resolved